hey Samuel leaves here and this week we
have a fantastic guest on interviewing
winners on a Wednesday but just for the
record next Wednesday
there will be no winners on a Wednesday
interview as usually as we don't know
Wednesday because there will be the full
documentary bompa bom of my financial
freedom challenge so don't it be
interesting times so that's gonna be
next Wednesday at 7 p.m.
Boxing Day but right now here's winners
on a Wednesday hey what's up guys Samuel
lives here we are on winners on a
Wednesday and this week's winner is the
amazing
Anthony Wilmots will Bob's your surnames
different on Facebook it is 5pi bro good
to have you on the show how do you feel
yeah X excited to be here very much when
did we first meet so we met on the crash
course end of April this year and then I
came to your deal friend in extravaganza
end of September so tell us a little bit
of background about yourself when you
decided to get into property what you
were doing and how they all came about
before you came on the crash course in
April so early early in January this
year had some some hardships go on at
home you know and found out I might be
becoming redundant in my job so as a bit
I'm not really sure what to do next with
my life I've been a retail manager for
nine years and thought I'm not really
sure where to go
contacted my brother and was just like
you know I didn't want to do so put me
in touch with some of your videos so new
brother said you're worried about your
job security working in retail yeah
watch these videos there's good help
right yeah he's like this is what I'm
looking to do long term in property or
was he just starting that interesting so
I dragged him along kicking her
screaming in the end is what happens so
I remember watching some of your videos
and being like why are we not doing this
and he's like our time money time money
and I was like no we're going for this
no force so he introduced you to the
YouTube videos yeah but then it was you
that then went wow and then you dragged
him to the crash course any much he
didn't really want to go your
backgrounds in retail where are you
based so a living crew from stafford
originally moved for work and various
things like that well your your previous
job yeah awesome okay so what happened
at the crash course so we came to the
crash course and it was
absolutely mind-blowing obviously we've
done some research prior to that and we
went away thinking this is great we're
going to get some deals we found a great
deal at the crash course and it was the
one that you picked to be the best deal
and purchased it which was great so you
came to the crash course yeah I actually
gave you money because you found it how
much it was two hundred and fifty pound
that we split between the three groups
great yeah it was good 250 pounds when
we come into a free crash else but but
presumably the value that you got from
the crash course far outweighed the 250
pounds that you've won yeah I mean it
wasn't about the money it was more about
the experience and about the value we
gained from it and I remember leaving
the crash course thinking had all these
ideas in my head the blocker for us has
always been money but for me it's been
more of a challenge how are we going to
overcome that there's people out there
like yourself that if you know money's
not stopped them so why was it going to
stop me and my brother so we went away
from the crash course I thought great
let's go we're looking for below market
value deals that we could buy and
refinance and try and use investors
money but that was hard it was really
difficult not having a brand and not you
know so we we we got loads of deals and
then approached investors and then
couldn't get the money so the deal fell
through and then we couldn't get the
deal so we couldn't get the investors
and it was challenging it was very
difficult well do you remember when you
came to the crunch course do you
remember what the deal was that I liked
so much that I gave you two new pants
yeah I remember we found a deal
in Blackpool member you said at the time
but you're like the ROI is really good
on it so it was 32% ROI and it was a
great house it was pretty much ready to
go so how did you at the crash cause how
did you find that deal then like
actually there on the day what happened
so like I said we've watched some of
your videos prior to that so we already
knew about sort of doing an ROI
calculators return on investment so we
paired with some people we didn't know
did you have any previous experience in
property or you did any property
training before you came on the crash
course no we'd been to some networking
events and things like that but no sort
of training or anything so how you found
the deal on the actual crash course
because that's crazy so we just very
quickly looked for properties that we're
going to hit the return on investment
and very quickly discounting ones that
needed work and that weren't going to
fit the criteria that we're looking for
because we only had a limited amount of
time I think it was 50 minutes I think
he gave us on the crash course so very
short amount of time to find this deal
very quickly just go through find the
house number on all of the bits and bobs
with that that went along it and then
worked out the rent in the area using
the tools that you've given us use that
to work out how much we could offer and
you know from that point if we looked at
actual market value that it was on to
offer versus rent we thought this was a
deal that would stack up and that would
work we know this people buying these
these renting these properties in the
area so we knew that this was going to
be a deal that would work for us and we
knew the only person at the event that
found a good deal oh no I mean actually
we were the sixth person that came up on
stage but lots of people came on stage
and a deal stacked up but they needed
work and this and the other and and we
were so confident in the end that I was
like just get me up on stage we've got
this we've definitely got and slowly
hands go down as we look into the
details yeah people realized this is
actually harder yeah it is than we
thought so so you finish the crash
course you've got you know you've had a
couple of days of training so before you
did any advanced training is that when
you started finding deals I'm really
trying to get
yes so implementation rather than that
did you sign up for the deal finding
extravaganza at the crash course yeah so
you signed up for the deal flying
extravaganza but you didn't wait you
said I'm gonna get started just after
the two days I'm gonna get started you
start finding good property investments
which are really good you know they are
because in your training but you haven't
got the finance for them and then you
can't find the investors and you're kind
of struggling a little bit so tell us
tell us tell us what the hardest thing
was at this point for you in your
journey the hardest thing is to keep
going I mean it's very easy to wake up
one morning think AHA I'm not going to
drive to my two hours to go and view
these seven properties that are hooked
or I'm not going to do this thing maybe
I won't make some phone calls and I'll
go shopping today and things like that
but for me this was really this is what
we were going to do going forwards you
know this is we wanted to be build great
houses build great properties you know
for people to live in and you still
working full time and yeah so I only was
doing I was doing you know there's two
days a week and I've been doing it two
days a week since so again you know each
one of them days off it's very easy to
go actually do you know what I'll have a
day off today but no I try to work seven
days through I try to make time for my
part now you know so we've got time so
you've worked really hard yeah so when
you came to the deal find the
extravaganza which for anyone that
doesn't know is a more advanced training
whereby you actually have more
one-on-one time to with coaches and
stuff to find deals so that what you
don't yeah it's more advanced what what
then happened because I remember on the
deal finding extravaganza I remember you
were doing really well and you're
finding really good deals but then on
the second day I believe it was you came
and your card yeah
yeah I had an accident on the motorway
on the way to the deal for an
extravaganza in the morning completely
wrote off my car managed to get safely
to the services thank God no one was
injured
and called my mom and I was like look I
need to get to this training course and
you come and pick me off so just
abandoned the car at this point
she brought me to deal friend
extravaganza and again like I said it
wasn't something that was going to stop
me
okay but I mean when you got back and
you told me what happened and you said
I've just been in my car yeah who's
gonna cost me what like a
yeah yeah they did to fix it's really
annoying and you didn't have savings or
no money yeah you had no money at all
and you were wanting to get into poverty
and the big problem was you're thinking
I'm only a neighbor in your car off and
you kept your head in the game and you
kept focused of course anyone's going to
be disappointed and feel a bit bummed
out but you said I mean I remember the
conversations they're not gonna that
stop me I'm gonna keep focused and I'm
gonna do so what happens so the deal for
an extravaganza really changed my
perspective on property because we've
had all this hardship we're trying to
find investors and and I remember you're
saying to me you focusing on the wrong
things right now I get that you want to
build a long-term wealth and long-term
portfolio but at this moment in time you
need to look for the quick wins which is
cash flow which will build you that
brand with people that end it'll help
you to joint venture with people because
I've said to you is you were looking to
build long-term well yeah but you
weren't particularly loving the job yeah
and you didn't have any money yeah and I
remember saying that joe said you you
need to get out of your job and you need
to get in with people and build your
brand and then start get the cash flow
going yeah because capital appreciation
is great but it doesn't play the bells
no it doesn't know and then once you've
got some cash flow then you can then
stop building your e-portfolio up and
after that happens then so we took
everything that we learned on the DfE
and went running with renter and just
mentioned the challenge because at the
end of the day everyone has to set a
two-week challenge so so at the end of
the DfE i me and my brother very always
like let's go for this full force it's
always 110 it's not worth doing it and I
said writing interview forty properties
in two weeks I'm going to make 20 phone
calls looking to looking for service to
accommodation went to rent deals and I'm
going to send out 4050 letters to HMO
landlords to see if I can you know help
them with their properties or look to
rent to rent deals and I remember you're
like so who's who wants to share what
they're gonna do in Assam I'll share and
and you're like you you won't do that
you don't have any properties so I took
that as a challenge instead I said if
you view 40 houses in the next two
weeks I will give you a check for 1,000
pound which will pay for your car pretty
much I know I said that because I knew
you wouldn't do it but but what I also
know was there if you tried to do it
you might view 20 yeah and I knew that
if you view 20 houses you would make
more money
viewing 20 houses off your off your own
back maybe by selling deals or whatever
it might be that with the knowledge that
you'd also had then you would make them
a thousand pounds yeah so so so after
that challenge all set tell me how many
houses and you mean did you do forty I
know how many do that thirty-two I
thought you might do twenty max so you
32 houses in two weeks is incredible
yeah tell us your experience of doing
those 32 houses with these houses was it
okay to just view any old house or were
they picked specifically because there
were a certain type of house no so again
we looked for ones that met the 20%
return on investment requirement that we
looked at yeah because we knew that from
an investor's point of view if that's
who we were going to target to get this
money that the deal had to stack up and
work so we looked at two types of
properties ones that we could buy do
some work on it and refinance and then
it's still achieved a 20 percent ROI
yeah and then we also looked at ones
that were ready to go bit of pain bit of
furnishings and also hit the 20 percent
ROI amazing and you wrote your finding
you'll find in these properties online
online agents you were going on gumtree
quite a lot open lane all the different
sites online someone markets some off
market is that right yeah so what
happened those days because they had a
coaching call didn't weeks yeah yeah
that's part of the deal binding
extravaganza we had like a group
coaching goal which was probably two
weeks in so tell us what happened at
that point so two weeks in I'd managed a
view about 27 I think at that point and
it said all in all we put offers in of
the 32 that I viewed on on all of them
but nine of them had had sold prior to
me putting offers in so we managed to
get offers on 23 of them that says
something about the market though nine
of them in salt that fast I mean some of
them before I'd even finished the
viewing somebody had had an offer
accepted that's literally how crazy they
turned her
because because well so we were looking
in sort of Warrington Wigan and crew
area crews very much on the up and
you're living in Cracow
so you were literally viewing houses
close to your home as well which is
which is good if you can do that okay so
carry on then what happens so we put
offers in on the twenty three and had
twenty one nose we had two accepts which
was great because they were below market
value we were confident that these deals
were great you don't know what you do do
market research you devalue the house by
looking at all the sold houses in the
street you were confident that you've
got two genuine below market value deals
but there was a problem right yeah what
was the problem
money yeah so who I am at this point we
thought we'd become compliant sources
prior to this and we thought right we'll
try and source these deals on the one
was really good and we thought we want
this for ourselves you know this we want
this to be the first house in our
portfolio so we were scrambling around
looking for investors looking to try and
raise the money for this one house the
one we managed to source on along with
another source an agent because we tried
to source it through our own list of
investors so it's very challenging when
you haven't got the brand and what
people are looking to do is they just
ask lots of questions because they're
unsure of you they're unsure whether the
deals going to stack or yeah and it's
lots of time wasted when you're on the
cusp of things because you've put this
offer in it's been accepted and you've
almost got a you know countdown a time
now before you've got to close the deal
because you have an offer accept it yeah
a landlord or a motivated seller said
yes I want to do that and then you've
got to go and find someone to buy it
yeah but what you do which is very
clever because you had no brand and you
didn't have a big list of investors
don't have time to build it up you found
someone that had and then you code deal
sauce the property so how much profit
did you make from passing that on you
didn't even find an investor you just
found the deal passed it on and it's
property do you make them that so made a
thousand pound on that okay which is
that was about at least it's gonna cover
all your time and expenses of you all
the houses yeah and that's the same
amount as I said I would have given you
40 so you've made it so that's fantastic
so you're a thousand pounds up what
about the other house
so the other the other house we raised
the managed to raise of Finance with a
great difficulty
struggle you're smashing it and we spoke
to so we were trying to us to be
creative with the finance and use money
that was gifted and things like that
through an investor and we spoke to
three mortgage brokers in order to try
and get the get the deal through with
how we wanted it to so obviously we
managed to raise the money we're also
going to pay for the refurbishment
ourselves my brother and I know credit
cards and things like that because we
know that when we refine that's out on
the end we'll be able to pull that money
back sound borrowed money from what like
a family member it was an investor so
obviously through networking events
through obviously we've put some videos
up to explain what would do income
where'd you learn to do all these things
all three self which is great because
you know the amount of people that then
now approached me and said I've seen
your videos on YouTube long oh that's
great I mean even being on this video
now witness on a Wednesday you're gonna
you're gonna massively increase your
personal brand but you're only on this
channel now because what you because
you've done some really really good
stuff and it's just it's so balls your
hardest and as always which one your
first your first one and then the second
one's a bit easier and the third one's a
bit easy so you made a thousand pounds
which was really hot and then you
managed to race in finance by putting
yourself out there and following the
steps that we taught you about how to
race find out how much money did you
have to raise so for this one we raised
just under 20,000 pounds what was the
what was the arrangement are you paying
investment are you gonna give them a
slice of the deal what did you do so
what we'll do is we'll give 10% return
on investment on the money
for how long for as long as we need the
money so this is the great thing about
it because it means that when we
refinance the deal if something has gone
wrong and for some reason we don't
refinance out at the price we thought
we're going to refinance the house up we
might leave four or five grand of their
money in but still be able to pay them
that temper
and died and which is very very clever
and it's also very good that you've
planned for the worst you've got you're
not because when you're doing buy of
refurbish we finance yes you can't pull
all of your money out you can but
there's no guarantees exactly because
sometimes it doesn't always work like
that sometimes the refurb costs more
than you thought
the builders take longer the evaluation
comes in lower than you hope sometimes
about value is all along to themself and
they make the decision so it's a very
viable strategy you can pull all or most
of your money out but what you've done
which is really clever is you've said
but I'm not gonna I'm not going to let
myself become financially crippled if
that doesn't happen I'm gonna prepare
for the worst and best case is amazing
worst case is okay and likely case very
good which is fantastic so that's great
you've now got one buy to that property
which is going to be making you some
cash flow presumably yeah so on this one
will be making 322 pounds cash flow so
if we have to take out it's 32 percent
ROI on this one then if we take out ten
percent we'll still make a decent
between just briefly in case anyone's
thinking oh my gosh credit cards between
good and bad so I think the difference
between good day is obviously service
serviceable debt so because we're using
this money on credit cards will continue
to pay bits of it per month but it's
something that's going to generate as
cash flow in the long term so and by
obviously having that and paying the
minimum payments and things like that
it's not doing damage to my credit
report because obviously we're still
service in the each month yeah so you're
borrowing money to then maintenance yeah
rather than borrowing money to buy
something which makes you feel great and
have nothing to show for it yeah okay
they're just off those two deals alone
the warrant made you a thousand pound
which
coverage of running around expenses then
you've now got a free house I mean let's
not let's not under that wasn't no money
down deal with you you raised money from
an investor you're going to pull
hopefully all or most of them anyhow but
even if you don't have ten percent but
the deal is going to make thirty two
percent yeah ten percent you'll get
twenty two percent and you're getting
the house yeah very much so
which is fantastic so so but there is
more all there's more so like I said
obviously the other things I said I was
gonna do on the DfE was make phone calls
send out letters so I sent out eighty
four letters to hate remote landlords
off the landlord read off the HMO
registry in two counties just seeing if
they were interested in getting together
for a coffee or if they needed any help
or they were looking to offset their HMO
properties made loads of phone calls
looking for rent to rent deals rent to
service accommodation deals I think I
made 32 in the end over about a three
week period yeah definitely well I
remember one day it is tough because you
sit there and you come off the phone and
everyone says no and it does hit you
hard but like you say you've got to keep
going you're a naturally resilient
person and that's did the train you had
at the crash course on the deal finding
your stopping hours and did we did we
almost set you up to expect that as well
yeah because you know I work on
statistic basis so the things that have
been said to me at the crash course and
the DfE set you up for the fact that
this is going to happen it's going to be
a tough journey
you know property is easy if you put the
right things into it but it's going to
be tough and it's going to be hard to
get there you know and when you read
people's inspiring books like the go for
know book I almost go for that no you
know it's still tough even though you go
because it's so you know if you get if
you you know if the statistics are it's
40 phone calls to get one yes but
actually you ring two people and get two
yeses you might think I can sit on my
laurels now if you're going
yes whereas if you think Gratton ring 40
people today and get 40 nose you might
end up with five or six yeses because
you've gone for the nose you're gonna
your statistics are higher and that book
as well so I got contacted by a very
motivated landlord that looked to offset
his to hate remote properties and I
thought this was the deal that was going
to be make me financially free we went
had a meeting he told me everything he
wanted I worked out the numbers and they
were great and they really really
stacked off he was happy we digged the
number so he got more money and some
respectives of it and it worked out
really well and I remember contacting
you and and about it and explaining what
had happened and then it was great and
on the day that we were going to sign
for he come back to me and said that
he'd spoken to a family member who told
him that he now needed to charge me an
upfront cost for these these two HMOs
which was just a figure that I couldn't
pay to him and all of a sudden I lost
these two deals which I thought were
going to make me financially free
they were going to get me out of work
and it was tough but for me it's like
this finite you know I remember
contacting you in saying look it's just
discipline your disappointment and move
on to the next day so important
discipline it disappointment celebrate
your success but you can only do that
when you first learn to disappointment
and for you I was real it was a real
knocked out because you know it would be
coming into the Christmas season so
where it gets tougher at this point yeah
I thought it's fine you know what makes
to my phone calls and phone call after
phone call and then I managed to get in
touch with a landlord that wanted to was
really interested that we were offering
him serviced accommodation went to view
the property and then I've done a renter
and here I sold it like geez it's a lot
and this is why we're now focusing
around the renter rents because I'm not
I don't want to overstretch myself and
try to juggle lots of things I do well
someone is a good property investor is
someone that's valuable and someone that
can find someone who's who's stuck a
motivated seller they can have different
strategies up their sleeve and say how
can I help ya that's really what you've
mastered and you've implemented you've
learned well you've taken good notes and
you've gone out and you've implemented
which is going to service so well so
you've just recently secured a renter
serviced accommodation yeah that's
correct and that's which is an area that
I know at all
so in Sheffield tell us about that deal
how did how did you get that and what
are the figures so we looked at
Sheffield because I went to university
there I know the city center really well
and absolutely loved the place and
thought I want to focus there because I
know lots of people travel for work lots
of people travel for leisure as well as
I thought we're going to tap into a
really good market of different types of
people coming to visit the area for
serviced accommodation a service
accommodation so we looked at other
statistics of what other people would do
in and what the figures looked like a
new we'd get a good occupation rate of
about 22 days 67 percent of the month
yeah on good months so we managed to
strike the deal with the landlords did
you find the Langille direct no so we
found it yes sorry we found him direct
through so you find direct through what
through gum tree gum tree I know what
gum tree is is very valuable for finding
people say oh there's not enough leaves
actually there's new motivated sellers
put in their properties and then the
bottom numbers on gumtree every single
day exactly so come on let's just let's
just learn the skills implement and pick
up the phone and we'll do a deal all
right
and this landlord actually was a no to
start with so you were like yes go for
now yeah well exactly
you know just return to me do it yes but
I rank him and he said I'm really sorry
it's just gone somebody's taking it and
that's like that's fine let me explain
to you what I was trying to do so if it
comes up in six months time again I'm
still here and he contacted me two weeks
later and said look this guy's fallen
through are you still interested because
I've obviously done the done the work
with him a set him up for that
he got back in touch me which is great
relationships
deals exactly we went to view it and I
was astounded by the property I thought
it was amazed and it was a really good
value we worked out the figures and went
through the contracts with him and he
was well he was really happy with it you
you picked up the keys how many weeks
ago so we picked up the keys 24 days ago
24 days ago and then you had to do just
a fellowship yes so we we furnished part
of it sounds a part of it how did you
afford to pay all the upfront costs or
were there not many up foot costs so the
the upfront cost was we paid at my first
month's rent up front as a bit of a
guarantee for how much so on this one it
was nine hundred and fifty pounds so
nine fifty is what you're paying each
month you paid that upfront what else
did you pay upfront so that was it
that's all we paid him upfront
okay and no other costs no other cost to
him and then we we paid for broadband
for six months because we were really
lucky the building we was in gave us the
facility to pay six months up front for
broadband and get cheaper we set up the
service fees and things like that and
then how much did it cost you in total
did you do all the setup so the 9/5 date
what about everything else of fun so we
did pay some for some furnishings and
things like that which again we leased
the furniture did you buy it
we brought the furniture much and so we
paid two thousand two hundred and that
was everything so that's all the better
how much all together the whole room so
in terms of paying the upfront costs and
what we've paid it would be three
thousand one hundred where did that
money come from so again we paid that on
credit cards we met we had some money it
you know saved to pay for the deposit
but all the furnishes and things went
onto credit card 0% yeah how long ball
for six months but then you'll probably
have to transfer again yeah there's a
card which is cool oh you must feel how
could you sleep at night
all these nervously tell me in the last
when did it go live so it went live 24
days ago we're live 24 hours ago did you
get the two days prior to that okay so
in the last 24 days how much money have
you taken in from bookings in that
apartment
so we've taken 10,000 pounds in bookends
pounds that is incredible and of course
some of that is going to go towards
you're gonna have to pay towards booking
booking fees like booking calm or
whoever and some of that is going to go
on cleaners and Yang's but that's still
gonna be a hefty amount profit and
that's gonna be every month now which is
just incredible so let me ask you a
question are you financially free yeah
very nearly almost pretty much that get
in there
so what's the next steps for you that
now you've done multiple deals you don't
nobody that in fact every deal you've
done there's been no money down you
don't know we've raised financing there
made a deal
you've sold properties Co deal sourced
you've now been a renter serviced
accommodation which you've done on a
credit card yeah now another situation
whereby how much how much cash flow do
you expect now you've seen everything
set up to the making from everything
that you've got set up so far so the
serviced accommodation we're expecting
between six and eight and Japan cash
flow a month there's a minimum and the
household bring goes about 320 cash flow
in payments so and then you deal
sourcing and then deal source and on top
of that so I think you know we're
probably expecting to be making fifteen
hundred pound cash flow per month yeah
if we keep continuing the work level
we're putting in at the minute
have you got other deals in the pipeline
so again I'm spending all my days I've
still working looking for rent to
serviced accommodation deals I've got
two that I'm really hoping they're gonna
make it through the line both fingers
crossed we'll see how they do on
basically the next thing that happens
you're going to be pretty basically
financially yeah basically when are you
hoping to quit job or how much time I
have so I'm hoping to quit my job
enter January at the end of January
fantastic I think you're going to do
that what I've been the key lessons I
know I know
in one sense people could say watching
this interview sounds like it's been a
real struggle you've week and you've
been gone but really I mean you only
came on the deal finding extravaganzas
are like what a few months ago yeah so
this has all happened in just three
months it's short term bank sorry it's
short term pain for a long-term gain and
we call it delayed gratification so what
lessons of success would you pass on to
people that watch this I think in all
I'm prepared to work seven days a week
I'm prepared to grind I'm prepared to
hustle I'm prepared to do that for a few
months to get to where you've got to
skills and tips would you give them I
think that the most important thing is
to never underestimate the very small
things that you do it might be that very
small post on Facebook it might be that
video and like I say every single piece
of time that you've got is valuable
whether it's to go to a networking event
to speak to people you know every single
person that contacts me I never dismiss
them you know because somebody wants to
ask me a question so I'm going to answer
it and you know education might change
after this video but education is
valuable to people and you know if I
hadn't have done the things that done
through education I wouldn't have been
able to take that information on board
and obviously use it to help myself in
my own successes yeah so think really
that's the key is you know get educated
and that's why I don't know what you
don't know is young and then that's why
I do I do that's why I run a training
program isn't for people like you that
are hungry that are prepared to do what
it takes but need the tools and need the
implement and that you can't I can't
make anyone successful all I can do is
give them the tools and tell them how to
use them and then it's down to people
like yourself to put the work in which
you've done really well and I'm really
proud of you as a student how's your
brother man how does he get about it
then oh he he loves it I mean my brother
takes care of a lot of finances and
things and he's still working full-time
as an electrician yeah you know but he
he rings me up every couple of days and
we talk about where we're up to and when
he rang me and I say just just run
through we're up to his bookings and how
much you're making and and when he told
me the figure you could hear the
giddiness in his voice yeah you know and
and we really are gonna build a great
legacy for us and not it's gonna stop
and this is just part one this is after
three months yeah I imagine what's going
to happen after three years exactly it's
just it's just incredible I'm really
pleased for you what advice would you
give to someone watching missed it was
weighing up whether to go to the crash
course or not I know maybe they had all
these reasons why not to go it's far I'm
tired or I'm scared that it's just going
to be a waste of time what advice would
you give to them I think the most the
best piece of advice I can give is just
go out and do it because you know we
don't question second-guess yourself
when you know we've been conditioned to
go through educate
we don't second-guess herself when we go
to university and we pay a huge amount
of money to do something like that
so if this is something you're really
interested in then don't second-guess
yourself and go out there and do it go
out there and prove to yourself what you
can do but be prepared to put the work
in because that's what it takes and
don't expect somebody to hand that
you're on a place because it always will
be the wrong thing absolutely yeah did
you have any idea and I know at the
moment you're not making you know tens
of thousands or anything crazy but
you've got some serious success and
you've died with nothing at all and now
you're going to be quitting your job in
the next month or so which is incredible
did you know how fast this would happen
did you have any idea how or didn't what
was your thought if you were speaking
yourself six months ago you'd have told
yourself what was going to happen what
would you thought would you believed it
no I mean six office ago I told myself
I'd be think to quit my job in 18 months
if we did all these little steps and I
didn't expect things to go your 18 month
plan went into like a three six minute
plan which is just incredible thanks so
much for coming on the show
I'm sure they'll be a part thank you so
much thanks Samuel my name is Samuel
Leeds thank you for watching winners on
a Wednesday every single week we
interview a success students for your
inspiration you can watch more right
here on the playlist as a whole playlist
of them but what you'll notice is every
single winner on a Wednesday always
starts with them coming to my two day
crash course so if you would like to be
a winner on a Wednesday literally come
on my crash course and who knows in
three months time you could be here in
my offices on this show as a winner on a
Wednesday so get yourself booked on the
crash course watch more have fun I'll
see you next week